what's up everybody its Warren and in a
really awesome turn of events today we
have some amazing news from Marvel and
Disney not only did they confirm that
they are going to be releasing not three
but four movies a year from here on out
in the MCU but yesterday we officially
got news that Marvel has just released
five new dates for upcoming MCU movies
that were not released before one of
them has to be for the Fantastic Four
and the final slot presumed to be for
the x-men's official MCU debut and just
to clarify these are all officially
movie spots and not spots that will be
reserved for Disney Plus shows so five
new theatrical movie slots have been
officially announced so we're going to
break down each release day slot and
which upcoming phase five movie could be
coming on each date but real quick if
you'd like to please subscribe to my
channel with notifications turned on I'm
giving away an Xbox one or a ps4 as well
as an infinity Saga collector's box all
you have to do to enter is subscribe
with notifications turned on leave a
like on this video and comment down
below with your thoughts on the video
it's hard to believe that there was once
a time where we only got two MCU movies
per year and now we're going to be
getting four a year for the next few
years
Marvel already had three MCU dates lined
up for 2022
February 18th May 6 which has now been
confirmed to be a black panther and July
29th but now they have added one more
MCU film to come out in 2022 on October
7th along with this announcement Marvel
and Disney also announced that there
will be four MCU movies in 2023 these
movies will be released on February 17th
May 5th July 28th and November 3rd now
not too long ago Marvel and Disney did
say that they would be releasing
somewhere between three to four MCU
movies a year moving forward well now
it's officially for a year which is
super exciting but even more exciting if
you consider which movies are probably
coming out in these dates and we know
which movies are already in the works
that have been announced by Marvel
Studios the movies that have been
announced being the works our guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 Captain Marvel - Ant
Man 3 blade and of course the Fantastic
Four and the x-men and not to mention
Deadpool 3 should definitely be on it
way as well Ryan Reynolds has been
teasing Deadpool in the MCU a lot but
let's go back to some original reports
from the gww and MCU cosmic that said a
long time ago that the Fantastic Four
movie will drop in 2022 well now that we
have an extra date in 2022 this is
proving to be more true
so the Fantastic Four could be taking
the 2022 spot and as far as the rest of
the slots go we have a pretty good idea
of which movies will fall into place as
I mentioned before black panther 2 has
already been confirmed for a 2022 spot
and the next two movies that will
probably come first
our Ant Man 3 and Deadpool 3 because the
rest of the movies that have been
confirmed are most likely a ways out so
2023 would work and based off of
everything that we know all the movies
that are confirmed to be in development
we should be getting blade
Captain Marvel 2 and guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 in 2023 but then we have
that final spot which should be reserved
for something big and that would
normally be an Avenger slot but let's
not forget what Bob Iger CEO of Disney
has recently said we are living in a
post Avengers world now
no Avengers teams in the upcoming future
and let's not forget what executive
producer Tran Tran has said she said
that she hopes to get to another
Avengers in-game type of movie within
ten years
well 2023 is pretty much three years
away
unfortunately we probably have a while
until we see another Avengers movie
however fortunately for us they will
most likely introduce the x-men Marvel
is going to need a big movie but they're
not going to be doing an Avengers film
so what could be a massive team film
that could take the place of the
Avengers the x-men are the perfect
choice and not to mention Kevin Feige
has confirmed that they are working on
the x-men
so the x-men will most likely go to that
final 2023 spot and this is what
everybody is pretty much assuming is
going to be the line up right now for
phase 4 and phase 5 of the MCU based off
of all the movies we know are confirmed
and if this does end up to be true the
next three years of the MCU are going to
be absolutely insane
Deadpool the Fantastic Four the x-men
all properties that have come over from
Fox finally in the MCU if this ends up
being the lineup what do you think about
this would
this make you happy leave a comment down
below letting me know your thoughts on
this and again don't forget to subscribe
with notifications turned on and like
this video so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
or an infinity saga collector's box as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof